[موسيقى]
ترتبط سلوكياتنا الحياتيه والنفسيه بل
المناخ فنحن لا ناكل ولا نشرب ولا نلبس
ولا نسكن الا على مجرياته فالصيف له ماكله
ومشربه وملبسه وكذلك الشتاء ولا نقيم
منازلنا سواء كان ثابته او متحركه الا على
جهات الشمس ففي الشتاء يرحل الباديه الى
الصحراء والحاضره في منازلهم وفي الصيف
يرحل الباديه من مساكنهم الى حيطانهم
ومزارعهم ويوجد فيها الابار التي يتحلق
فيها الباديه وهي موسم تبادل المنفعه
والتعارف فيما بينهم امر على الديار ديار
ليلى اقبل ذا الجداره وذا الجدار وما حب
الديار شغفن قلبي ولكن حب من
سكن الديار
[تصفيق]
ومع دخول موسم الربيع الفعلي في شهر مارس
ينتشر الربيع ويتمايز نبته وهو مرحله
جراند خامس والذي يقال فيه جراند خامس
ربيعا طامس ولهذا تسمن المواشي وسميت
العقربه الثالثه والاخيره بعقرب الدسم
نتيجه لهذا والعام ما يسمونه بموسم صياح
النبات وهو الموسم التي تبكي وتصيح فيها
الطيور حزنا على فراق الربيع الا وقد
هاجني فزددت شوقا بكاء حمامتين تجاوبان
تجاوبتا بلحن اعجمي على غصنين من غرب
وباني
[موسيقى]